hello i'm taylor page play zola hi i'm
riley keough hey i'm nicholas braun hi
i'm coleman domingo
and the cast of zola here is taking a
quiz to see if we can actually survive a
wild weekend
thank god it's friday it's time for your
weekend of fun to begin but first
where are you going miami ibiza
jersey shore nice vegas cabo new orleans
i'm gonna say cabo new orleans because
i've had wild weekends
there and i want to go back i'm going to
say ibiza i feel like i can have a
really good time there like the good
kind i feel like the other places are
pretty dark yeah i've fallen off a
balcony i did it for my girl
oh yeah thank you taylor
the second question is who are you
bringing on this weekend of fun my so
my squad of homies my family my one bff
me myself and i or some girl i just met
who promised me a good time
my squad at home goals my squad of
homies yeah me too my squad of homies as
well my squad homies who's gonna bring
some girl i just met who promised me a
good time
nola did that
[Laughter]
my family who's gonna bring a family to
a weekend of five that was my second
choice
it really was well your family's pretty
fun the night is young the fit
is poppin and it's time for your first
activity what's your first stop the
casino
the dance floor the strip club a
michelin star restaurant
a concert or i don't know we'll see
where the night takes me i want to see
this difficult because that's the movie
we're making
you gonna start there okay i love that
that's like a last stop start there
yeah i think that's the last stop i
think you got to eat first right night
is young
yeah i would say michelin star
restaurant you need a good meal and then
you can do whatever you want see i put i
don't know we'll see where the night
takes me because you could be on your
way
eating and you're like wait a second
let's go in there i'm down with michelin
star myself too i feel like
the first meal you haven't gotten
hammered yet enjoy a good meal oof
last night was a blur and now this
morning you have a hangover what are you
eating dry toast
a breakfast burrito gatorade nerd
water and advil a bloody mary
eating more like praying to the
porcelain altar i would say a nice
bloody mary you just gotta just keep it
going just a little bit my god
i'm a really bad drinker so i probably
would be throwing up
i'd probably drink gatorade i'm a
breakfast burrito person generally
that's one of my favorite foods so
that's what i'm going with oh no
memories from last night are coming back
to you when you get into some trouble
what did you do did you streak through
the hotel lobby
lost a lot of money at the casino dined
and dashed
got your wallet stolen danced on top of
a bar
made out with someone you shouldn't have
i would say that all of us would
probably
do all of them
it all sounds like a good night on top
of the bar
i think i would make out with someone i
should have oh more likely lost a lot of
money at the casino because i've done
that throw another hundred at it and
then
you're deep you're deep in debt it's
just bringing up a lot of
memories drama i'm gonna go with dance
on the top of the bar pick a
rambunctious movie to watch while you're
nursing your hangover
the hangover project x super bad
house party spring breakers or ma
i feel like i would like watch something
like the color purple
yeah if i wasn't feeling well i feel
like you want to watch something a
little slower and not as like
yeah that's just too hyped up i know i
don't want to watch super bad
house party because then that's like so
different than my own reality so that's
like a little far back how's parties
actually stressful
i think i'm gonna pick super bad i'm
gonna pick super bad too a little
nostalgic i'm gonna change that maybe
the hangover because
you know that whatever you did is not as
bad as that that is there
yeah finally pick a word to describe
your weekend now that it's come to a
close
we didn't go crazy enough i would say
but the options are
wild memorable litty chaotic
bonkers messy you are messy your brain
is broke yes you better give the
performance of your career
nick it's alliteration 100 people say
litty
oh it's litty our weekend if we just we
had a michelin star
meal wouldn't be messy no memorable i
like memorable you're right
i'd say wild because i say wild a lot i
was wild
you survived the weekend and lived to
tell the tale you had a good ass time
and me some shmoney
and can't wait to do it all again next
weekend so wait why not you didn't
survive the weekend okay you did
oh yeah who you didn't survive mine was
incredible my friend's willing to pick
you up or bail you out of jail
and look at it this way at least you've
got a cool story out of it
what reminder says your weekend was a
trip and a half but you made it back
home in one piece the only word to
describe your weekend is messy but you
made it out and that's all that matters
i i didn't think a michelin star
restaurant qualified as messi
right but did you pay the bill ah
there's the rug
what where's my wallet i don't have my
wallet
thanks buzzfeed and make sure to watch
zola
you